[Music]
for you it's that time that nice nice
being lazy night but we get that [ __ ]
feeling search for beautiful night in
paradise every salmon the best thing is
you here with us
don't get no better than that they
playing [ __ ] make-believe we don't
make believe we give a [ __ ] about what
you give a [ __ ] I'm saying
you
how's that for a [ __ ] cloud
[ __ ] uncle Joey here looking like
Tony Pepitone on 154 and Calabria Avenue
you bad [ __ ] at schmuck
Wednesday night the 17-8 who gives a
[ __ ] you're here you quit that's it we
got a great show for you tonight
my main man big brown is on his way
we got reefer we got edibles we got
everything we got the cantaloupes
we got the [ __ ] chocolate boss we got
Larry pills it's all over tonight
[ __ ] you wanted it you got it we
got some [ __ ] containers I'm a man of
many containers you know I'm saying
I got containers everywhere in the
[ __ ] in my office not these type of
containers you're [ __ ]
why would I have Tupperware containers
unless I'm saving [ __ ] of this shitty
food you eat that [ __ ] lizard me
they're gonna shut down ooh
caffeinated alleged in tourism in
essence what complication definitely
something you Tanya you got to watch
where you eat these days
[ __ ] cockroaches [ __ ] I know when I
go into a place with a cockroach each
type of people first thing I do is I
judge the glass of this fingerprints on
the glass I don't need to only think
that because if you can't watch the
[ __ ] glass you can't wash your hands
and if you're working behind the counter
you see a glass is dirty and you don't
have the initiative to clean that glass
I don't want to do [ __ ] business with
you that's separate how do you judge
things that's number one a dirty [ __ ]
glass because if the glass is dirty that
means they're a small wait ten [ __ ]
philly goat you understand me
speaking of billy goats it's time for a
bonnet ruling
let's do Liana
right yeah we're walking around tonight
I miss being a billy goat that has to be
me speaking of [ __ ] the greatest of
all time we [ __ ] pull the loose I get
ready for the spot go go that's the one
that's the one that killed the mule oh
[Music]
my god that's the one that killed the
mule you people think what I'm serving
here is [ __ ] my faithful we got this
[ __ ] that [ __ ] kill Lincoln
everything's Lincoln got shot in the
head l know he won he bought some weed
for some black dudes it was tremendous
you follow me that was the real amount
of patient information
[Music]
oh that's the character is dead let's
try this but if this garage dude oh [ __ ]
ra's dude showed up last night at the
Comedy Store that's my little brother
Raju don't be [ __ ] with them
[ __ ] I'm gonna Pink Floyd type of
mood cuz if you want to see the devil
you got to put on Pink Floyd you
understand me all your [ __ ] is Dave
Gilmour coming at you like a [ __ ]
Tyrannosaurus who's ready for us 250
milligrams choppy raise your hand
that's right [ __ ] that's how
we're doing it on a Wednesday night what
do you guys do tonight you know the
ladies night is it [ __ ] you [ __ ] all
that nonsense you with uncle Joey
tonight we got you we got red stars we
got blue eyes I didn't believe it seen
the [ __ ] booth bugs all you have look
at this woman's conglomerate twinkle
twinkle little star how I wonder who you
are
[Music]
we got the earthquake ranking where did
it go
we got back up baby peg you got listen
you get drunk you got stuck on the
Buddha lounge it's always a good night
are you ready to smoke some more you're
gonna sit there like a [ __ ] bumpy on
a lot and if you're under 18 and up now
moneylady 19 and we start later his
reply was how many we got film phantom
leaders elevated himself up the ranks of
being a goddamn [ __ ] THC Killa
I know what else it is
we had a great podcast coming at you I'm
rested I went to jujitsu today I didn't
my meetings I got stones I listened to
[ __ ] Gilmour this morning for
breakfast but then you listened to go
more for breakfast you can't go wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a man like that
[Music]
[Applause]
will that nail the [ __ ] the top
prophecy
oh [ __ ]
and here we go are you [ __ ] nothing
what wake up a syringe it's that type of
night I know you told you eight I know
you told your partner you're not doing
any more but it's all over here we go
and when you lose control oh [ __ ] here
we go you read this you have sound too
much too [ __ ] much too much a [ __ ]
mental you put that whole arm on turn
the lights out it's a field right you
will understand me because you see [ __ ]
you ain't never seen before
who's ready for a bomb can be said what
the [ __ ] both hands are up here we go
[Music]
where are you and in certainly what are
you [ __ ] nuts
what would you rather be hanging with
hanging out at Starbucks analyzing
buddies I'm gonna so Scotch me one next
year who gives a [ __ ] you're right
here's a [ __ ] if you're right here we go
nowhere in the salmon stay right here
boo do it with me I stay the mountain
stop stop oh oh oh oh oh are you [ __ ]
nuts
ask me upon the water oh oh oh oh oh I
was like 16 on a [ __ ] hit of
windowpane you got the [ __ ] go a lock
you have the lights on living like one
Campbell run it and you got this on your
[ __ ] earphones are you kidding me are
you [ __ ] kidding me that's why I used
to put myself through every [ __ ]
night just to prepare myself for the
[ __ ] future of debt boom and
destruction if you can live a night
through that you can put up with [ __ ]
anything you understand me you think
you're dealing with the enjoy your
[ __ ] bananas or what coming at you
live on periscope smoking bong heads
eatin edibles it's a free church people
get your [ __ ] together
enough is enough don't make me put the
[ __ ] national anthem on and make you
all get up and salute the flag
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] if he game
ends over the rock who gives a [ __ ]
about the GOP who get it's all about you
[ __ ] get that bong get that boat
for telling him a [ __ ] get that rock
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing let's do
this [ __ ] let's go deep in the murky
waters on the underworld you're going to
call your sponsor
jelly's on periscope he's wanted me [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
you can even see what kind of space
want to be my robot nobody ever Hagel
they just worried about the barn it is
coming at you look at this this is a
beauty Omega for you ready this is a
[ __ ] beautiful
you know it's always all yen now it's
your attitude back nobody [ __ ] up it's
your attitude always remember that
[Music]
you're at a gym room ready and you
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up
you ain't [ __ ] up you as tough as the
rockatuer broke keep it keep it right
there that's the one that's the one that
saved Jesus McCain don't take it out
right there don't take it out yet
Canaria get that going look can we go no
but we're to go away so King you better
not once again let's go get in here see
you I gotta let you [ __ ] up let's go
over here are you gonna stay right there
over some time plate on second shoot
again there you go no bet the fury
covered in leather say he goes Lahey is
something with the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with here I'm training a [ __ ]
soldier here the [ __ ] jump over walls
and iran and capture people oh shoot
PPAC tablets this [ __ ] like every think
I'm building it you think I'm [ __ ]
around
well so you got some chocolate well even
truck listen
hey you're coming to the Voodoo Lounge
if I am fighting Telemundo lounge we
prepared George Korres his friend came
Shana start you can go to work the next
leg again the family
everything happens when you walk into
the Voodoo Lounge everything change
listen was I talking T I'm talking about
mommy I'm talking to them I'm talking to
you right away what would you take I am
right in the making
what Brendan what [ __ ] break who
needs a break dream bring some for union
members you didn't it
you got a union card note here do i all
right I smoked pot for [ __ ] on a union
of deck and that means there ain't no
[ __ ] breaks [ __ ] what am I to
do with these pigs stop coughing you
[ __ ] up the transmission [ __ ] drink
some water either called drunk that's
going to another bonnet or the other
[ __ ] here the Skywalker hobby Lou it's
[ __ ] beautiful
oh all I do is put my fingers in the
fingering on me I'm already finger they
can get my hands in front of the heater
it was like 82 degrees and I had to
either on my wife comes in she's like
why why does swimming in and what the
[ __ ] do you think I got reefer and
process understand I'm making things
absent on my table I'm Pablo Escobar
without the [ __ ] ball anyway
who said Bobby that's what I'm talking
about man let's listen and my world we
go heavy duty if not what a [ __ ]
pre-k get your diploma come back in fact
I'm not obviously I'm talking for them
again you didn't go to print not pre-k
with little kids and [ __ ] dogs and
[ __ ] I'm talking about the pre-k school
of reefer where you hang out with your
buddies and I love this lemon twist og
get the [ __ ] out of here
the flavors huh it's a body hard I want
to smack those [ __ ] people then I'm a
little bit confused no [ __ ] uncle Joey
look at you you're going Claude Lee wake
up only half way down there the mission
is oldie how do I smoke it all day
because this when we [ __ ] do
professionals don't talk they don't put
posters up a reefer they don't go to
reefer conventions they just like that
[ __ ] house on fire and a solo tip
understand me enjoy your Lincoln no I
don't have no Lincoln big profile if you
try to be my friend on Lincoln then go
[ __ ] yourself
I want to be nobody's [ __ ] friend on
Lincoln ding understand me I got enough
problems I had a joint professional it's
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] my friends was
on [ __ ] Facebook
[Music]
and no one has a real friend things to
do would be sighs too late the winner
[ __ ] lobby where you want [ __ ]
Jesse where you at Charlie where you at
with where you [ __ ] that you
got me over here with [ __ ] Joe slowly
and for him you don't want to do
chocolate
who said friends here who said who's
ready for some French chocolate then
what the [ __ ] here um saying anyone
vomit or some struggling to jump off the
bumper exit there yoga one longest the
time I got one one left that's it that's
all I mean is one one it's a little
jiu-jitsu in time every two minutes I'm
breathing for [ __ ] I'm here we go
are you [ __ ] nuts and you're talking
about trade school
there we go here we go
[Music]
listen guys right now go iTunes get fake
voice welcome animals
and [ __ ] [ __ ] the numbers do what
happen in a windowpane turn the light
off and give me your phone right me and
milk no more because that's the resistor
we allowed it someone will take you to
the next [ __ ] level how do I know
does it elevated me correctly and then
what the hell my finger roll it was over
I was a different man a week later and
you're done drinking turned 18 hang up
now
three no look you're here we'll put this
one back in there I'm going to the
Skywalker just cuz that's how we'll roll
it just to the top
[Music]
full of a spit and the fan are you
playing it is a brakeman who was told
what to do by the man
[Music]
there we go a little scary what we want
to change it up a little bit change up
the Janaka quoi of the room you'll say
you guys don't know if we're Joy's in
financial even though I don't have a
platform the back of the back oh my good
ear we go who was chasing away who was
breaking away who was only a stranger at
home are you kidding me who with only a
stranger at home who needs this [ __ ]
that like this will [ __ ] take it back
then you what a psychiatrist temping
million I can fix it do it again the
next time
that's it absolutely
[Music]
are you talking you ready
absolutely [ __ ]
there's the Skywalker I got it I got to
review them all but while I do he got me
on hold he one of the secret mission had
to go back to [ __ ] Tel Aviv and pick
up a shipment of Krav Maga [ __ ] new
chop see okay hold on let me switch this
over let's get the [ __ ] pigs cooking
let's get sheep let's blast this
[ __ ] to like I go to the
bathroom go pee we'll get a survey so
whatever you need to do help people get
I'm back alright that's I'm quick shut
the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] what are we gonna say this
[ __ ] on him falling [ __ ] here we go we
ready a blast-off empty bond let's fill
this buckle up
just call me Joey Houdini a little
Skywalker oh yeah a little tooth roots
and you guys are going to sleep I
[ __ ] babies tonight who said this is
better than [ __ ] Gabba Gabba
this is better melatonin this is Bette
this is the best [ __ ] sleep you wake
up in the middle of night thirsty [ __ ]
all you got is ice tea you drink after
walking fetch it you're peeing you go
right back to the [ __ ] crib nothing
but [ __ ] Z's understanding James told
me that one's for you [ __ ] you ain't
got a job James told me well you need a
fancy suit to work for let's get this
reef round let's get some of the FBI
reforge aims cool me whatever your
[ __ ] name is leave the party started
you got about a week do you guys take
another piss test just a [ __ ] whether
you're running things game called me
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright [ __ ] we got [ __ ] to do
people to see and people to make it
happen with understanding its
youtube.com / c / joey Boogaloo des no
no yes it's youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
the church Brendan Schaub gonna talk
some [ __ ] tonight about comedy oh he got
into comedy the whole [ __ ] deal all
right you want to talk about fighting on
his [ __ ] 510 this is uncle Joey's
podcast we do what the [ __ ] I want to do
[ __ ]
hey guys doing alright you know I love
you [ __ ] listen we'll get this
podcast started and that's it last night
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz you miss
dammit youtube.com so that's Lee said
Joey be it next Thursday night the
Icehouse and dollars workout night
that's it I got a list of [ __ ] I want to
talk about we talked about it we smoked
a bowl you go home I go home every time
you got Memorial Day weekend alright
state black youtube.com slash C / LED
you know I love you [ __ ] no
matter what are you and that nothing Oh
God
stay black remember if you think of my
mother not being a liar
we'll get the legal you
[Music]